bang
bang lunch money time or while she's
trying to get rich the rest of us trying
to get her lunch money right
i'm here with carol [ __ ] uh oh wait
sorry
polina marinova pompliano what's
up whoa guys it's getting real for those
that don't know
pelina's middle name is e vilova and so
if you put paulina paulina
the initial spell pimp let's not get
that
going when i found that out i knew we
were going to get married let's not get
that going
don't forget block fight now sponsors
lunch money
if you go and open an account before
july 18th
and fund it you get two times the amount
of interest in their interest bearing
account for the month of august
no brainer they pay up to eight point
six percent interest in their interest
bearing deposit account go and sign up
use the link in the description no
brainer
all right what's up miss pompliano
all right i never thought this day would
come
so make sure you enjoy it because it's
probably not gonna come again
it will but you're right
in the beginning of covid when you said
that the coronavirus would act as a
catalyst
uh for protests around the world
say that again for the people no no no
no say i was right no
no okay okay but major protests are
breaking out against governments in
several countries after coronavirus
sparked fury over grievances including
economic problems
in alleged corruption or incompetence uh
israel
lebanon my own country bulgaria
serbia people are just raging against
the government saying that they're using
coronavirus to um
kind of to manipulate the people be a
dictator
yeah look at the end of the day again
whether right or wrong
you cannot as a government tell your
people to go inside and
not have a path
for a prosperous life i think serbia is
rising up because they put
on these um what's it called uh
curfews yeah so like here's a perfect
example right
if if uh if you look in uh new york city
right now
there are laws in terms of or rules and
they're not sexually laws the rules in
place
of how many people can gather an outside
uh location
so if i wanted to have a concert right
now and i said you know what i'm only
gonna have
i think it's like 500 people show up
they would come and they would shut it
down and say you can't do that
but what compounds the problem then is i
look outside my window
and there's five thousand people
marching down the street in a protest
but it's a project
but that's allowed what's a protest
again
but that's allowed and so regardless of
whether you think what's right what's
wrong
doesn't matter what you end up having is
there's too many people in a population
to please everybody
and so you're always going to have
somebody who's upset but
this gets kind of put on steroids when
somebody says wait a second i can't go
outside and earn a living
yet the people are out there and they're
protesting in the streets they're doing
all this stuff
and so what you then get is you get
multiple types of protests so the united
states you get the social
um kind of civil rights type protest
right where people are saying hey we're
protesting police brutality we're
protesting
uh racism all of that kind of stuff i
actually agree with that
we should all be in the street right but
then on the other side you can't get mad
when people say wait a second you're
taking my ability to make
money away from me and everyone kind of
was scared back in march this is the
most important part because this is
going to get worse here's my next
prediction not only that there's going
to be protests all around the world
it's going to get worse from here and
here's why
in the united states in march there was
absolute chaos and uncertainty there was
this economic shock nobody knew what was
happening and markets were dying all
this craziness was going on
the u.s government stepped in and when
they stepped in what did they do
they flooded the market with liquidity
they literally
three trillion dollars of liquidity in
the united states
the federal reserve's balance sheet
expanded by and so when that happened
everyone said wait a second is this
really going to be that bad
i'm going on unemployment i'm making 600
extra on top of the unemployment
insurance
i'm actually making more money than i
was making at work wait a second the
stock market's going up like this isn't
that bad
but the relief is going to run out
so at the end of this month as of right
now that extra 600
a month for unemployment insurance
that's gonna go away
the stock market can they pump the stock
market all the way until november to the
election
we're gonna find out but at some point
it is the pain of the recession
is exposed you know screech to a halt
you just
can't cover up the pain of the recession
and so that's what's going to occur here
is wait till all of a sudden
the relief payments the stimulus checks
the bailout money all that stuff starts
to run out
wait till all of a sudden the people who
received ppp money or
bailout money can start firing their
employees and all of a sudden they're
dumping
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
employees on the street i have two
things
yes one i read an article that talked
about how small
a lot of small business owners are
finally like throwing in the towel and
saying
we can't go on any longer because there
seems to be no end to this
foreigners are opening shutting back
down and what pisses me off the most
is that the governments have kind of
been able to get away with blaming the
people
like you are the problem you're not
wearing your masks you're
putting us in this position and it's
like no sir
you had no plan to begin with here's the
hot take of all hot takes cause it's not
really a hot take
if you look at the coverage of andrew
cuomo who's the governor of new york
this is the best example i have
andrew cuomo is responsible for over 30
000 deaths attributed to covet
new york state has more deaths than
anywhere else in the united states
by to almost 2x the next highest state
from the
last numbers i saw was 17 000. so new
york state
is the worst state by almost 2x andrew
cuomo is on television taking a a
victory lap
he's literally talking about how we're
new york tough we you know we
uh we crushed the curve all this stuff
hey idiot
you single-handedly were touting a
policy in which you took covid patients
and sent them back into nursing homes
afterwards which led to an immense
amount of those 30
plus thousand deaths were in the nursing
homes in new york
and then because his brother is a cnn
anchor
he goes on cnn and him and his brother
are joking around
but here's how i know the tide is
turning jake tapper who's a cnn he
it's a colleague of andrew cuomo's
brother recently
called all this nonsense nonsense out he
said
you guys are taking a victory lap you're
literally selling posters about being
new york tough
you're doing all this stuff saying how
good you did you got 30
000 people killed you more people died
in new york than anywhere else that's
crazy
and this is getting exposed now because
now the people are waking up and they're
realizing wait a second
the government not only killed the
economy the government
got people but if you think about it
people aren't just gonna
sit around and blame themselves they're
gonna try to find a scapegoat in all
this and it probably will be
the government at some point of course
anyway what's going on with twitter
how's my rant for the day welcome back
okay twitter um there was a massive
twitter hack
yesterday of the accounts that were
hacked were president
ex-president barack obama joe biden
amazon ceo jeff bezos bill gates
and apple and uber corporate accounts as
well as
pop star kanye west is he a pop star or
is he a rap star oh look at all the
people
yeah look good mayweather i mean i'm
kind of upset i didn't get hacked if
everyone's gonna get hacked like hey he
was sitting here being like oh my god i
can't tweet does this mean i got hacked
and i was like
chill out i can't i can't tweet either
and i'm sure they didn't hack me
so long story short what happened with
twitter is uh there are now reports
surfacing that in
underground hacker forums people are
coming out and saying that
uh some of these hackers paid a twitter
employee
uh that kind of went rogue to give them
access and there's this admin dashboard
where basically you can do all kinds of
crazy stuff including tweet for accounts
and all that kind of stuff
and so obviously um what has occurred
here
is a inside attack right like basically
they got inside the twitter account
two things that i think are really
interesting one a number of people
reported that their accounts were
compromised
even though they had two-factor
authentication on so that means that
basically they were sim-swapped
no oh the the two-factor wasn't foiled
but they still were able to get access
to the account because once you get
inside the system
basically you have all these extra
controls right and so
it's very rare that somebody gets inside
twitter usually it's they're hacking the
end user
this time they hack twitter and we're
able to do stuff so that's first of all
second of all is there was only a
hundred thousand dollars sent
to the bitcoin wallet address it's still
a lot of money
my guess is nobody sent money my guess
is that that's actually the hackers
sending transactions to make it look
like there's actually
uh people sending money in you don't
think a single person was like let me
pull up
well when i first saw the the report
very early on like 4 30
or so there was a hundred thousand
dollars that had already been sent
and by the end of all of this there's
still like i don't know 110 000
so my guess is that the hackers did a
bunch of the early transactions
and then through the life of it there
wasn't that much more money set hackers
freaked me out
yeah but you know whose account wasn't
hacked donald trump do you know why i
said that
i was asking do you know why no but i
was asking because his account
previously had issues that it got
deleted by a twitter
uh uh employee previously i think it's
like hyper secure
that's what the reports are saying is
basically after that past incident they
put
even more security around the president
united states account
so it was even harder to get in so now
my guess is that they're going to go and
they're going to do that with all
verified accounts
do you guys remember when that like
foreign exchange
not student but like worker at twitter
accidentally
deleted trump's account no no no no
no deleted it it wasn't accidental it
was like accidentally yeah it's a
malicious like rogue employee
i don't think it was malicious positive
positive
there was no action let's put it this
way that guy doesn't work at twitter
anymore
okay ready yeah what's going on with
stockx stockx is an
online sneaker reseller it has seen a
huge surge in the number of air jordan
shoes submitted and listed to the
website
after the last dance documentary came
out
that's so crazy that like a documentary
can have such a huge impact on
businesses like that
well just reminded like the generation
of kids today
they know that jordans are valuable but
yeah they when they hear
jordan they know he was a basketball
player but they think of the brand like
oh i wear my jordans really
right i don't think that yeah because
like that's what it is right it's all
about like buying jordans collecting
jordans doing all that
then they watch this thing they're like
oh this is where it all started so of
course there's going to be a resurgence
in
uh one from people who watch michael
jordan play there's nostalgia like man
he was so good
two is a bunch of kids are like damn he
really might have been the best player
in the world
and then three is people who see the
shoes like here we go here value goes up
again and so of course there's going to
be more economic activity as
there's price volatility similar to what
happens with bitcoin or stocks
and so i mean like it makes sense but
it's cool to see the actual data and see
the ceo of stockx like confirm
yes we're seeing way more interest after
that documentary jordan effect
israel by the way ben baller who i've
had on the podcast
awesome guy uh if for those of you who
are into uh music and stuff uh you've
probably heard in the songs ben baller
did the chain
he does all of the celebrity jewelry uh
ben uh
first made money he had a massive jordan
uh sneaker collection and sold it for a
couple million dollars so there's uh
people out there who are like
really big sneaker heads and can make
quite a bit of money if
they're smart about how they collect
shoes all right american airlines
let's talk about your american area
so american airlines said it backed
union's push
to extend payroll support through the
end of march 2021
the airline statement came in a furlough
warning to 25 000 employees
airlines can't lay off any more work any
workers until
october 1st under the terms of the 25
billion
uh federal payroll aid situation the us
government was a sucker in the room
wait so what are they asking for they
just want to extend well
a couple of things have happened so
first the airline industry has gotten
decimated in terms of demand right
because of coronavirus
and so revenue dropped off a map uh the
federal government stepped in and bailed
them out and what they basically did is
they gave 25 billion dollars to the
airline industry
of which approximately two-thirds was a
grant
one-third of the money was a low
interest rate low so the low interest
rate loan we lent you the money you pay
us back with you know one two three
percent interest
fine still not great terms but at least
the
american taxpayer gets interest on their
money the two thirds of the money was a
grant it literally was just a freebie
and the reason why i say that government
was the idiot in the room or the sucker
in the room
is no investor would ever give a company
billions of dollars
without getting interest or equity for
that capital but the us government did
it
so part of the rules uh of accepting the
money was
you cannot fire employees you cannot
change their salary
right or lay them off yes fire them
right lay them off
uh and and kind of all of these other
aspects to it
what people are already forgetting we
have short-term memory loss is
what the airlines actually did though
was they would say something like you
know what
plano you get paid twelve dollars an
hour we're not going to change your 12
an hour because that would violate the
rules but you work 40 hours a week
this week next week you're only going to
work 30 and they took
hours away so they ended up paying
pelina only
three-fourths of what she previously
made but it still fit within the rules
it was a loophole that they found and so
that kind of violates the
spirit of the deal but two is now what
they're saying is
hey in october we're going to fire a
bunch of people or
foreign because they have to they can't
make the economics work
and so yes the u.s government's
injection of capital has
postponed or uh these issues
but at some point the government or the
airlines are gonna have to do this
and so what so you're saying like it's
there everyone's just gonna
dump people oh yeah unemployment's going
to
explode when all the pvp money you
basically they can
get unlocked and they can fire everybody
but what they're asking here for
is can we get more money through march
of next year right like
it's not as abrupt well then it'll just
be abrupt then
right like they're hoping that demand
comes back same thing with the
unemployment insurance if unemployment
goes
uh out in july all of a sudden a bunch
of people are going to be
making way less money and without a job
than
right now do we think there will be
protests in the us over unemployment
and lack of jobs and yeah i mean look i
i
have already said this before i
personally believe that majority of the
people that are protesting
uh are doing it for police brutality
racism etc
there is some portion it may only be
five percent of people are out there
because there's pain around the economic
shock
uh and that has kind of um exasperated
the issue
if for some reason these benefits all
expire
and we see tens of millions of americans
on
uh unemployment and there's no hope
like hope is the most important piece
here because the hope of the economy is
going to reopen jobs are going to come
back i'll go back to work
at least people have something to look
forward to when the people lose hope
that is when you get the really bad
protest right that's when you get the
riots
and i think that's what we got earlier
well there's definitely a loss of hope
in terms of police brutality racism all
of that
if it happens on the economic side
you'll have even more people in the
street
all right google me google is taking on
zoom and slack by building video calls
and chat into gmail for business users
i'm sorry google nobody's gonna use your
thing ooh
i'm not gonna use them so that means no
one's gonna use it hot take
i think actually a lot of people use it
um aggregate number
but in comparison zoom is more popular
i just nobody says hey do you wanna
google video
no but because of
the moat it has in terms of being in the
google calendar invite and things like
that right there's still plenty of
people that use it i don't know if they
publish any sort of user metrics but my
guess is that it's
tens of millions of people use it on a
monthly basis um
so they're gonna so their gmail has 1.5
billion
active users g suite has six
okay hold on six million businesses in g
suite but but what but it's
what's interesting is it's going to add
the video thing to um
google sheets so uh google docs sorry
so when you're like collaborating on
something you can just like video call
the other person who's in the doc yeah
that's kind of nice
look i i'm not a google hater like i
love google but that's what they have to
do right to compete in this world like
they're gonna have to do things that
they have an advantage to do that other
that zoom of the world can't do so like
that makes sense my mom's favorite
company is google because she says she
doesn't know how she used to live
without it
okay migraine drug what okay
so this is interesting i don't know if
it's interesting but it's just kind of
odd
so biohaven pharmaceuticals lands khloe
kardashian as influencer of its new
migraine drug
um so i know this happens like there's
spokespeople for drug companies but
it's kind of weird now like to have an
influence or market
or be the face of your migraine drug uh
it i mean it really depends there's kind
of two ways to look at it right so first
of all
does it make sense from the company to
have somebody who's so public
uh
this is a no costing uh to go and
publish the uh or go promote it and
drive sales yeah that makes a ton of
sense
what i'm actually kind of surprised by
is once you get into kind of the heavily
regulated industry like healthcare or
finance
and you have influencers like it'd be
kind of weird to see khloe kardashian be
like
hey go buy you know biohaven
pharmaceuticals for your migraine
by the way disclaimer you know there's
surgeon general says
well whatever so she may come up with
something kind of unique in how they
present that but there's definitely
going to be
more restrictions around what can be
said and how they do it than in but i
just always
i always worry when you put influencers
promoting
drugs because it's like suddenly what if
there's a surge in this migraine drug
for people who don't necessarily need it
and they're getting prescribed and it's
just i don't know
i don't like it i don't know either but
look this is the way the world's going
influencers run the world what's up with
mars all right there's a helicopter on
mars
yeah nasa's mars
perseverance rover is obviously the star
of the mars 2020 mission
the rover is designed to be the most
capable piece of hardware ever sent to
the red planet
and it will have the ability to sample
the martian soil search for hints of
ancient life
and even pick up samples of soil to
eventually return to earth but is it a
helicopter
so it's a pint-sized dual propeller
helicopter
that will ride to mars in the belly of
the perseverance rover
what yeah they're going to send a
another mars rover and the rover comes
equipped with a helicopter but the
helicopter doesn't have
any specific objectives related to mars
exploration it's more of a proof of
concept than anything else
that it's possible to fly in the
incredibly thin martian atmosphere
that's kind of cool yo humans are
awesome
they're like yeah we can't send humans
tomorrow we're about to
we're gonna sell a helicopter look at
this tiny little thing that is
awesome but so it'll just basically test
what do you think the aliens would do
balls when they saw a helicopter flying
around
like damn we didn't think y'all could
get here now y'all got your helicopters
but they have a rover thing there
do we send it with weapons no why don't
you need weapons there's like no life
there's like barely
dirt what do you mean there were no
aliens on mars anthony
speak for yourself did you know there's
water on mars no
fact google google it real quick hurry
up we got 10 seconds
not really but we got time mars water oh
almost all water on mars today exists as
ice though it also exists in small
quality quantities as vapor in the
atmosphere some liquid water may occur
transiently on the martian surface today
but limited to traces of dissolved
moisture see everybody needs to read the
internet just because there's water
doesn't mean there's like
beings you didn't even know that water
was on mars until
14 seconds so just so we're clear
if there's water on mars and the
atmosphere is similar to earth
why couldn't there be uh life on mars
there could be
there is probably okay ready for my joke
yeah what's up
cool cats and kittens um okay oh i
forgot it
you forgot the joke no you can't say the
joke is over it's over you forgot the
joke it's over did you forget it again
no why did the bicycle collapse
why did the bicycle collapse yeah
because it was wheeling no wheeling and
dealing
no because it was too tired
what get it two
tired like two tires but it was t-w-o
like two tired come on
[Music]
if you gotta explain the joke it's not
so funny i normally have to tell the
joke to intelligent people not people
who are like what
if can i give you a suggestion on your
joke telling what if you emphasize
the parts of the joke then people will
laugh too tired
because it was too tired
i'm not speaking so you see
all right guys that's it for lunch
monday today while wall street's trying
to get rich the rest of us is trying to
get our lunch money right
pelina will hopefully bring better jokes
because if she doesn't the joke segment
is going to
get left on the cutting floor
see you guys tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind paulina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends